oh my God
time travel has been a concept that's
intrigued me sure enough it's also
captured the hearts of anime fans of all
ages whichever genre they like it's not
quite as widespread however upon looking
back at some of the key shows that I've
seen as well as going through some
footnotes in anime's long history it's
quite nice to see that the concept of
going back in time has played a role in
giving us some of the most popular and
memorable titles that we've all enjoyed
and that's what we're going to do today
go through 20 of the time travel anime
series of movies that I found myself
loving the most the first anime on the
list is Buddy complex
[Music]
foreign
travel seem to be a natural combination
given how much the latter lends itself
to a Sci-Fi setting yet it feels quite
rare possibly owing to Mecca's places a
pretty nice genre as the 2010s came
around 2014's buddy complex made the
premise work and it remains one of
sunrise's more interesting Works around
that time buddy complex feels like a
Gundam show at first glance which isn't
surprising considering sunrises role in
it the main difference however comes in
the form of the protagonist's big
decision coming in the form of involving
himself in a battle in the future all of
that is a bid to prevent his gruesome
end in the present and to figure out the
secret behind his classmate who came
from the future the mysterious Hina
yumihara buddy complex aims to give its
fans The Best of Both Worlds and while
not as lauded or popular as sunrise's
biggest hits it deserves a bit of your
attention
next up we have Future Diary
when we mention Future Diary it seems
that its time travel aspects get
undermined especially from people who
haven't watched it and only heard of it
after all it's not primarily known for
the time travel but more for the violent
finds in yandere post to charge you no
gasai that's not a knock on it though as
the battles here can be quite intense
and attention-catching especially since
the position of being the god of space
and time is at stake Future Diary is one
of the edgy fan favorites back in the
2010s and it remains wild entertaining
and downright brutal it's one of the
most well-known titles with the Battle
Royale premise and I do think that none
of the similar shows that came after it
had quite the Legacy it had sure a lot
of fans and I enjoyed things like
Darwin's game or glypener but they don't
quite hit the same high in terms of
cultural impact
reset is the next title on the list
much like a title that we'll be
featuring way further on this list
sakurada reset has a cover and an
overall appearance that makes people
think of it as a slice of Life show with
a premise that features a guy with a
photographic memory and a stoic girl who
can reset time the ground seems to be
set for a drama with a dash of action
adding to this is the presence of a
bureau that keeps tabs on people with
powers and assigns the duo on missions
and like sakurada reset I really do but
I still got to admit that it's quite a
tough sell to General audiences due to
its Slow Burn approach if you didn't
think that it's a slice of Life thanks
to the cover it may give off Vibes
similar to an action-packed modern
fantasy featuring people with powers
however there isn't much action and
everything basically builds up to a
narrative that has a nice philosophical
touch still you should give it a try if
you're someone who likes these kinds of
shows overall I do find it very
compelling it's just that It ultimately
remains something for a specific Niche
ready to dive into more Niche shows his
debunk fresh from 2004.
foreign
myself into thinking what the most
realistic time travel show could be the
premise itself lends to Fantasy already
but I'm talking about what a careful
person would reasonably do after the
time travel that's where Z Barn comes in
which revolves around the crew of an
advanced warship finding themselves in
World War II with their Advanced
Weaponry they know they can easily turn
the tide of the war in favor of Japan
but this isn't that kind of show and
perhaps letting history take its course
ends up being better still staying
Anonymous and not touching history when
you're dead center of it could turn out
to be a task easier said than done
zebunk's probably the most obscure show
that will feature on this list but it
does have a unique aspect to it instead
of people going ham with the time travel
and altering the past how about going in
the other direction surely it's not
exactly the more compelling course of
action between the two on paper the
zifong manages to hold my attention with
his Cliffhangers something to take note
of definitely
before we continue let me ask you a
question have you ever felt that feeling
you just can't get the right content to
watch while you're scrolling through
tiktok and YouTube shorts well let me
introduce you to one of the best
platforms for niches like animate and
gaming and the sponsors of this video
fresh cut fresh cut was built for both
creators and their fans where you can
watch content that you actually like
best of all it was actually built by a
team that used to work with Twitch in
his 20 plus years of combined experience
through fresh cup you don't have to keep
scrolling until the algorithm recognizes
that you actually want to watch anime
clips rather than Minecraft Parkour
speedruns when you open fresh cut you
get to choose which Community you want
to focus on and all the content fresh
cut gives you is from that Community
alone they have new features like
diamond tipping you can send to help
your favorite creators as well as in-app
quests that have a daily streak system
to make watching videos even more
interactive best of all just like an RPG
game there's a shop that you can use
your earned diamonds to buy gift cards
Riot points merch and loads more so what
are you waiting for take a look at fresh
cut now thank you Fresca and back to the
video Let's fast forward to the modern
era with remake our life
oh
remake online throws our protagonist in
a scenario that we've likely come across
in our own lives it just feels awful
when you get past the point of no return
and invested your efforts in learning
something that just doesn't pay off
luckily kyoka who's at the dead end of
his career and aspirations gets a second
chance finding himself 10 years in the
past he decides to attend an art school
instead of pursuing a course in a
business University this puts him in a
team with a successful female creators
that were the objects of his Envy in his
previous life if you're looking for
something that deals with the
entertainment and game industry in your
time travel show then you've come to the
right place with this one I've long
considered sekano as one of my favorite
rom-coms and this show scratches the
same itch giving audiences a cast of
charming characters along with some fan
servicey Harem hijinks there's a lot of
fun to be had with the cast of remake on
life and it's easy to tell what kind of
show it's going to turn out to be from
the get-go try it if you're into that
sort of thing
foreign following that we go to the
sengoku era for ambition of Oda noguna
a personal favorite of mine ambition of
Oda nobuna sends our protagonist
yoshiharu back in time to the Warring
States period only for him to find out
that the Warlords from his knowledge of
History are girls he also finds himself
a member of the Oda Clan as a
replacement for toyotomi hideyoshi who
gave his life up to save him with the
irregularity in history and his new Rome
yoshiharu looks to set things straight
and guide nobuna this world's female
counterpart to the famous Oda Nobunaga
in her quest to conquer all of Japan
surely his knowledge will come in handy
not only in military Expeditions but in
also steering Noble Knight away from the
violent fate that was in store for the
actual Nobunaga it's very very easy to
pass this off as your typical Harem
rom-com with historical and Military
elements but honestly that's one of the
things that initially drew me to it
however upon rewatching it I found
myself quickly engrossed in not just the
budding relationships between the
characters but also how it Incorporated
actual history in its narrative there
are lots of genuinely hype and touching
moments for this show and there may have
been cast off as a seasonal filler back
in 20 2012. it's a really enjoyable
watch so much that the lack of a sequel
is something that I still feel bad about
let's feature the first movie on the
list her blue sky
huh I've got to admit this movie here is
a fringe case of time travel if it's
even that still I grabbed the chance to
feature this film that I felt needs a
little bit more love being a winding
Journey that has no shortage of drama
and plot twists meeting your past self
opens up a lot of possibilities and her
blue sky runs with that concept and asks
us questions about it the story sounds
really promising and original but if
there's something I have to give praise
to it's more of the movie's production
art as expected from a theatrical
production is exceptionally nice also
it's from the team behind anohana so you
see some familiar elements if you've
watched the former it's not exactly a
masterpiece but it's still a good watch
if you're up for watching an anime movie
I still believe this could have worked
better as a full-blown series but it's a
pretty nice film for what it is
the world in colors deserves a mention
too
thank you
[Music]
losing your childhood as you reach the
older stages is one of the things that
hurts the most in this anime's case it
hurt Hitomi so much that she started
hating magic and stopped seeing the
world in colors to throw her a bone her
grandmother casts a spell and sends it
into the past where she finds herself in
the artist yurito's room will this
person be the key for Hitomi to once
again see a world filled with color one
look and the knowledge that this is a PA
Works anime are all you need to get a
gist of what to expect from iruzuku I
really got what I came for with this
show excelling and sending the audience
through a creative and magical Adventure
as with most of the Studio's shows
iruzuku is a wonderful story of
character growth full of ups and downs
set against the colorful backdrop that
looks as beautiful as advertised the
shows a nice recommendation for anyone
looking for an original anime that's a
treat to the heart as much as a treat to
the eyes
huh
[Music]
the trip to the sengoku is not quite
done yet with our next title Nobunaga
concerto
[Applause]
oh
if I had to pick a title on the list
that's all about looking and feeling
unique no Ronaldo concerto would be at
the top of said candidates that's the
thing that stands out to me with
Nobunaga concerto how it looks it's a
pretty short anime clocking in at just
10 episodes but those 10 episodes are
filled with quality mainly detailing
cyborough's mishap of getting sent back
in time and finding himself as a
stand-in for the legendary Oda Nobunaga
unlike the previous entry that has to do
with the premise ambition of Oda nobuna
Nobunaga concerto concerns itself more
with a grounded take or history if you
think nobuner's gender-bending
action-packed and fan service you take
on the same Goku era isn't quite your
cup of tea you can probably sink your
teeth into this title VR does take a
while to get used to but I found myself
adjusting quite well just a few episodes
in Orange is our next title and it does
time travel in a unique way
understand
a simple title for a show that cuts deep
into the heartstrings orange is a School
drama detailing takamiya and her efforts
to change the future Guided by a letter
from herself 10 years into the future
she tries her best to correct her
mistakes while trying to save a person
of particular interest the transfer
student Gaga as expected from an
adaptation of a Shojo manga orange is a
show that's character driven and Rife
with emotional story beats I also give
it props in the unique take on the time
travel aspect where instead of the main
character traveling through time the
plot revolves around the present with
the time travel aspect mostly confined
to the letters it can get quite
melodramatic at times but I don't think
it's to the detriment of this story
about friendship and grabbing hold of
chances life gives you
[Music]
and if you're enjoying the video and
want more content like this don't forget
to drop a like And subscribe while
you're at it alright it's time to start
meeting the second half of my top 20
list next we have the girl who leapt
Through Time
foreign
the last year of high school is such a
crucial part of our Lives as we prepare
to take the leap to the next phase of
our life it feels so make or break it
would be sweet to have the power to
travel back in time and do everything
right just to make sure we don't mess up
it's such a crucial juncture right we
just need to be careful in messing with
the past though as every choice leads to
a consequence and that's the overall
message that this award-winning movie
gives us it's an Aesop that we've heard
of before but that hasn't changed the
fact that the movie presents those
lessons in an excellent and enjoyable
manner the movie isn't too long either
being just around about an hour and a
half but it ties everything in a
conclusion that's all about Hope and the
brightness of looking forward to the
future a great watch for the family that
I strongly recommend
foreign
for those who are around in the 2000s
he's Inuyasha
time travel and an aspect of isakai
before it's called here's Inuyasha for
you lots of people back in my Elementary
and high school days just can't get
enough of gargoma's story of finding
herself in feudal Japan as well as a
quest with Inuyasha and the rest of the
team in regaining the pieces of a
shattered Jewel it regularly finds
itself along its long-running Shonen
contemporaries and it remains one of
rumiko dakahashi's most renowned Works
Inuyasha is insanely long for modern
anime standards but it remains an
enjoyable ride if you found yourself
invested in the characters early enough
they may not be the most unique ones of
the bunch but they do have some great
dynamics that make watching them greater
than the sum of their parts with it
being character oriented instead of
battle or twist-centric Inuyasha overall
gives a slightly different flavor to the
popular battle heavy Shonen of its era
and I think that's a pretty cool thing
to take note of that Army Galaxy is a
show I've been eager to talk about
[Music]
since I talked about Nobunaga concerto
why not also feature that Army Galaxy
like the former dadami Galaxy is a show
that you'd probably take note of due to
its art style one that allows it to
stick out for most anime that we're used
to seeing like some titles we've seen
that Army Galaxy revolves around a
person full of regrets about his college
life of course he gets the chance to go
back in time and write his wrongs a way
to set his life on the right path that
Army Galaxy is notable for its rather
surrealist art style as it explores the
endless possibilities a life can have we
get to see the DraStic effect of simple
decisions through this series of short
stories that oftentimes gives us some
lessons to remember rewatch bonus is
also a thing for this anime allowing
repeat watches to pick up on things that
make sense the second time around it's
something you could try if you want
something that looks a little bit
different yet remains relatable
[Music]
erased Finds Its way next on the list
water time 2016 was in the world of
anime sometime in the middle of the Year
an anime took the community by storm and
it was erased the raised runs on the
simple premise of the protagonist going
back in time to fix the present while
having zero control of the powerful
ability back in his schooling days he
gets the chance to investigate a murder
mystery one that apparently boiled over
to the bad present he used to have he's
got a lot of work to do and it all
starts with understanding more about his
classmates if there's a thing Our Praise
are raised for it's how well it does
Cliffhangers I constantly found myself
watching episode after episode because
the show has such great Mysteries that
you keep wanting more the more answers
get revealed the more questions follow
and you find yourself totally immersed
in the scenarios presented by the story
foreign
[Music]
next we have Tokyo Avengers providing
much welcome Hot Blooded elements to the
list
[Music]
if you want to time travel anime but
can't let go of Hot Blooded battles that
are as flashy and exciting as the other
mainstream shown in hits you've come to
the right place Tokyo Avengers has been
making a name for itself in the anime
Community for quite some time now thanks
to its cast of characters most which
exude a strong presence and a numerous
flashy fights it's got lined up it's not
too often you see a time travel plot go
this all in on the action and it's paid
off spectacularly on the part of Tokyo
Avengers despite all the good that can
be said with Tokyo Avengers I have to
admit that the show strongly resonates
with a certain type of anime fan those
who love their gritty action sequences
and cool characters there's some room
for character growth and while the main
characters are quite the polarized
reception the other members of the cast
contribute in giving the show an overall
Cool vibe
[Music]
opening my top five is VV
when it aired VV didn't exactly enter
too much fanfare sure it's got re-zero
guy's name attached to it and it deals
with a time travel premise but that's
basically it however the few episodes in
and it becomes clear that it was to be
one of the best shows of its season
Phoebe strength in my opinion is in its
themes and compactness it's paced really
well making sure that there's always
something to keep people coming back
week after week and the fights aren't
bad either it's got some insanely
fast-paced fights to help showcase the
anime team skill in more ways than one
Vivi just ends up being a very beautiful
anime in a literal sense great visuals
great music and some philosophical
subtext yeah the latter feels like
something we've seen out of a lot of
sci-fi's that deal with robots or AI but
in VV such themes were presented
masterfully
[Music]
foreign
at number four we take a look at link
click
[Music]
link click gives us an interesting
premise in that it's something that I
haven't exactly thought of before coming
across this anime for our two main
characters to travel through time they
use photographs quite a genuine premise
I'd say and it's something that really
teases my imagination what if we had
something like that in real life and as
a staple for the great shows in this
genre link click is just awesome at
creating Mysteries and Cliffhangers in
between the pretty visuals and the
fights link click is an underrated show
that fans of the genre should check out
while its fights are still a notch below
those from VV it's got a magic touch
that makes you just want to binge
everything in one go
what better show to start off our top
three than re-zero
for those who've been around for the
past few years you'd have surely heard
of this show at its very basic state
it's got a very intriguing plot
featuring puzzles that keep the viewer
engaged and waiting for the eventual
solution it's the quintessential
Thriller that just won't let you go as
more Mysteries unravel or while
supported by a lot of what seems to be
popular with anime watches in its time
namely the isakai aspect and the
abundance of waifu characters that
eventually get their time to shine it's
no surprise that re-zero became such a
Smash Hit Subaru himself remains quite
the divisive character but as we've seen
with Tokyo Avengers that's barely a
burden when so much of the show is good
the second season has come and gone and
I feel that it allowed the franchise to
show off how it can excel in multiple
aspects while the first one had better
action and a faster paced plot the
second one really shown in the character
development side
foreign
and if you can't get enough of re-zero
his summertime render
[Music]
just like re-zero summertime render runs
with the premise of having a protagonist
being able to go back in time after each
death however it turns up the stakes and
intensity of such situation up to 11
doing away with the isakai and veering
into straighter modern Supernatural
territory summertime render provides a
different flavor to re-zero's concept
but it's just as good I really love the
show for how well it does its overall
mystery and just how violent and tense
some moments can get it's also a compact
story that wraps up extremely nicely in
the two cores it got as an anime
summertime render is definitely a must
watch in my opinion the manga got me
binging and the anime improved on the
experience tenfold it really feels like
an extremely refined take on what
re-zero is doing and I gotta love how
much more suspenseful and high stakes it
felt
foreign
and at the top of the mountain is the
king of time travel anime itself Steins
Gate
[Music]
foreign
there's just so much that can be said
about Stein's gate and its time in the
Twilight of the Heyday of visual novel
and game adaptations it Rose Above the
Rest and became quite possibly a
contender for best anime of the 2010s
period it's got everything you'd want
from an anime like this likable
characters Clever Time Travel mechanics
and great production values the voice
acting something that people have given
much praise over but I still think that
the plot and story progression is
something else given how much I praise
the anime I have to say that it's still
not a perfect show by any means but what
show is it's got its flaws but it's
still one of the best sci-fi anime ever
made in the past decade or so and it's
something that stood the test of time
beautifully whatever kind of anime fan
you are you should definitely give this
one a shot even if you're not a fan of
sci-fi
oh
no no
that does it for my top ten my
conclusion is that the anime world has
shown the potential of time travel story
ideas by mixing it with all sorts of
setups and genres now there are some
titles that you might find conspicuously
missing but I decided against them due
to the time travel aspect being big
spoilers can you guess at least two of
them you don't have to leave it in the
comments but it's a nice thought
exercise that we can compare lists if
you want and don't forget to check out
fresh cup links in the description it's
been a pleasure to share my favorite
time travel anime with you and I hope to
see you for the next video that's coming
real soon so make sure to subscribe and
keep up to date with Vinnie tube see ya